rendez vous à 10 heures 30 au moulin de
la voiselle pour une balade originale à
chaque fois pour avoir
votre apéro et ça vous présenter ce ce
papier lie au tampon enfin les
participants paye 20 euros pour un menu
surprise qui sera servi dans différents
endroits de la ville je suis venu pour
la marche
j'ai vu qu'on pouvait boire et manger en
même temps muni d'un kit de survie un
verre et un plan de la ville autour du
cou
les randonneurs prennent le départ le
parcours commence dans les marais il
faut marcher deux bons kilomètres avant
de marquer une pause musicale pour un
apéro bien mérité galette aux pommes de
terre et verre de vin une quarantaine de
bénévoles s'activent sur ce premier tour
food à bourges
on a le temps chacun son rythme n'est
plutôt bien il fait beau c'est joli
c'est sympa ya de la musique c'est super
bien organisé c'est convivial
que demander de plus la balade gourmande
se poursuit ensuite dans le centre
historique
il faut juste réussir à trouver l'étape
numéro 3 le plat principal
bien caché dans les remparts de la ville
des convives sont accueillis par le duo
léonard
[Musique]
on découvre un petit peu le centre-ville
r c'est vraiment très sympa et on
retrouve nos amis et donc c'est c'est
super d'une belle journée
les deux associations de quartier
charlier bourbonnoux se sont réunis pour
offrir cette balade
objectif rapprocher les habitants et
dynamiser la ville c'est déjà un succès
on a refusé du monde parce que on savait
pas trop si on allait être capable de
gérer l'événement on s'est limité à une
180 personnes ce qui est déjà pas mal
est bon je pense qu'on peut faire un
tout petit peu mieux donc l'année
prochaine on fera une deuxième avec un
bond plus de monde le crottin de chèvre
se déguste à la bonne franquette au pied
de la cathédrale
une première édition qui se déroule sous
les meilleurs auspices